sam who should we believe
you or that's the question of the day
are we going based on your orders
someone give us the orders if we're live
send a tweet at me right now tell me if
i'm live or not because these guys are
telling me i'm not live yet
i'm telling you i think i am live we're
live are we live okay we are live thank
you david we're live folks anyways we
are back with the great ricky aguilar
and gerard michaels back in the house
you guys have never done this together
right now it's always been adam you're
sitting in adams i'm sorry i'm sitting
in adam's shoes
and gerard's sitting in his chair you
know where he's at right now so
have you guys ever spent time together
no this is the first he's flexing on me
all day
oh no he's he's been flexing on me shows
up with a
ten thousand dollar watch i'm like
what's what's going on we're talking
about flexing last night there was a guy
flexing at the house
till uh one o'clock in the morning our
friend uh phil heath seven time mr
olympia that was nuts we had a good time
with him yesterday you know you know
just just the crazy thought to throw out
there
a year ago i got myself in trouble okay
i didn't get myself in trouble but i got
you know phil and i were doing alive and
i said what if
what if i run a bodybuilding contest
show but i want the best of the best
show up
first place i give a million bucks okay
second place i give a half a million
bucks
but i want the best of the best of the
best and we sell it on pay-per-view
and it got feel a little bit in trouble
because you're not supposed to be
talking to the guy i mean this you're mr
olympia you're not supposed to do that
but you know what there's something
about the monstro olympia brand that
needs competition
i don't know why i just feel it needs
it needs somebody to ruffle the feathers
a little bit i think it's a little bit
too political
i'd love to see somebody come out there
and stare at a pod woman i was doing
bodybuilding interviews for a long time
we may be doing some surprises here soon
i don't know what it is but just
something about wanting to compete with
mr olympia excitement absolutely i don't
know what it is
i don't know what it is and i by the way
i don't even know if there's a big
audience for bodybuilding or not
i don't know if there's a big it is i
think there might be now more than even
before pat
there's a part of me that wants to agree
with you there's a part of me that wants
to believe that there's a part of me
that thinks you know vegans and all that
stuff
there's no world that we're living in
right now that people are trying to live
real healthy i think there's a bigger
market that you might think can i ask
you a weird question yeah
mr olympia how big of a brand is that
massive massive brand i mean
bodybuilding people okay arnold
lee haney yeah they have footage from
everywhere how many subscribers do you
think mr olympia's youtube channel has
you can't answer this
how many subscribers you think their
channel is i said like i said two and a
half million two and a half
uh i'm gonna go man that's tough can you
pull it up worldwide
worldwide they're a youtube channel yeah
i would say maybe uh maybe
four million four million okay i would
have said five kai can you pull up their
youtube channel right now to take a look
at this
you know by the way maybe help him out a
little bit go give him a subscriber or
something [ __ ] i don't know what they're
doing over there but
okay go to mr olympia's youtube channel
okay
here's a brand who the hell is running
this thing that can't even figure out to
get more than 31
000 subscribers if i'm if i'm a
bodybuilder
representing a brand like that you guys
got to do a better job marketing
you got physiques you ever see these
guys with apps post a picture 38
000 likes yeah these guys are posting 48
000 likes how do you not have a chat
all the footage they own they don't even
know how to market a brand like this
anyways i hope the new guy does
something about it jake would have heard
good things about him
but uh i think uh i think there needs to
be some kind of a shake up there
competition man i mean look this is what
i was hoping for i was really really
rooting for
vince mcmahon's xfl to actually do
something not to compete with the nfl
but
to maybe improve the brand give these
guys a chance to you know listen
that's one of the best things about
capitalism look what happened with rogan
and stelter right let's get right into
what happened with rogan and we are
by the way we got a lot of stories going
on okay uh uh gerard's favorite stories
the
nickelodeon story because jar group
hardcore on nickelodeon we got to touch
up on that yeah
justin bieber pretended to him this was
an actual interesting uh
spoof of what happened saying this isn't
justin you got the wrong guy we'll cover
that here in a minute
chris cuomo calling fox news a disgrace
you got
devin booker this might be a bad
president richard jefferson roasted mba
i mean it was devin booker stood up
uh and did something very interesting
that pissed off a lot of people
victoria's secret abandons
it's uh dressed angels saying they're no
longer
culturally relevant activists and
entrepreneurs will be the new faces of
the brand
it says will it work or not i guess
we're going to talk about that and some
stuff going on in chicago
but let's talk about let's talk about a
rogan and stelter okay
so brian stelter is with cnn right for
now
and he's got a show that is plummeted
tremendously i don't know if you're
familiar with
brian stelter's he you know they call
out typically
you know these youtubers because i can't
believe these podcasters are getting
more views than we are
so rogan decides to call him out and
here's what rogan said let's just read
this story here and let's get right into
it pedro are you in pattern i'm on page
six page six got it
inside joe reagan joe rogan's bitter
feud with cnn's brian stelter this is a
newsweek story
during the conversation with political
commentator kyle kolinsky
on the joe rocking experience rogan
described a cnn segment about the
popularity of youtubers and podcasts
in some cases have more viewers than
traditional tv networks rogan said of
brian stelter
who hosts reliable sources they're
describing as if they're entitled to
viewers
this is because the market has spoken
and your show
is often terrible rogan also
took aim at stelter for his recent
interview with white house press
secretary
uh in his in which he asked what does
the press get wrong when covering
biden's agenda
okay how about biden how about brian
stelter talking to the pres
now broadening his criticism to the
cable host in general rogan added
they're obviously being told a certain
amount of what to do
and i mean maybe he'd be an interesting
guy if
he had his own effing podcast if he
could just rely on on his own
personality and be himself i don't know
i can't imagine doing that gig
any of those guys that gig is a strange
gig right
so you talk about capitalism okay you
talk about capitalism
this is the ultimate capitalistic thing
taking place right now on media you got
these guys who went to
the columbia university they all did the
right way they got their jobs at cnn and
now rogan
is crushing these guys as numbers
crowder is destroying them and they're
upset about it what are your thoughts
about that
let me tell you man this is a great time
to be alive because
the funny thing about it is it's gas
lighting more than anything else
stelter's trying to say that because of
these podcasts people like rogan and
patrick bet david
they can get fake news they don't want
it's not fake news who's more fake news
than cnn
they're mad they don't have control over
the narrative these people
are so sick in the head this human thumb
that is brian stiller and thank you for
describing to your audience who he is
because there's nobody who's ever
watched him they don't know who he is he
is a human thumb
he is a propagandist of the highest of
the highest order
and this dude is mad that other people
can actually find news and information
that they want and they can't just
he can't just shove his world view down
everybody's throat
that's what he's upset about what is he
saying he's saying i don't want to
compete
i represent i'm a mouthpiece of the rich
educated highly
educated the rich hollywood elite and
you have to take what i give you when i
give it to you
shut up bend over people trust me rogan
or stealth
logan is it even a question no okay go
let's go through the list of the guys
that have their own shows right now
let's go through the list and tell me
who you actually
trust you gotta you gotta say someone
you trust from the left as well though
it can't be like so
okay i could give you a list of six or
seven lemon left don lemon no no i'm
sorry don lemon
no okay uh rachel maddow no
no anderson cooper no no anderson
vanderbilt okay
uh stelter oh okay uh bill maher
yes yes he's starting to be a lot more
honest jon stewart
yes okay russell brand i mean he's not a
media guy he's a youtube
guy but okay who else we got on the left
okay who else you got on the left right
now i can't go forward
all right there's a guy named jason
brennan from 200 proof liberals
i read almost every day and he he's a uh
he has a um
uh what's called um he's a professor at
university of georgetown matt taibi matt
tybee former editor of
rolling stone barry weiss from uh new
york times alex berenson these are all
what i would consider you know you like
the term jfk democrats
look i i am not i'm a libertarian i'm
not a republican
you know i'm not some far-right dude man
i have been the same we talked about
this a few podcasts ago
i had to really re-evaluate myself
during covey pack because i i found
myself like being
you know finding like things alex jones
was saying like wow all right like i'm
agreeing with alex jones i need to
reevaluate this is pause for
pause for concern but i'm in the same
place i've always been
it's it's the the culture's gone so far
left
so fast that it makes anybody who's in
the center or was in the center even two
three years ago
seemed like a far right what do you
think about zacario frieza karya
like okay good i disagree with him but i
i appreciate his approach i should
say i would i would i would agree with
that as well adam's a big fan of uh for
zakaria he sent me stuff he sent me a
couple things over the weekend i was
looking at how
he was presenting russia and iran what
do you think about what's going on right
now with the
the rogan stelter story no i i i agree
with them i think that uh i think what
what's happening is that
um there's a narrative they want to push
and anybody that doesn't believe their
narrative or doesn't buy into their
narrative becomes the enemy
right and so that people here's the
reality is that the media and the elite
don't want free thinkers
and podcasts are free thinkers for now
until somebody's
somebody's gonna get bought out
eventually right but they they peop
the free thinker scares the world it
scares the elite
because what happens you start to rally
people behind behind
hey let's question this maybe this is
not reality
you know it's it was i was talking to uh
um i was i was
telling him that i was at my family's
gathering uh this past
uh i think it was not this weekend as a
past weekend and we were having
conversations with that
you know like hey what's up how do you
guys how dumb do you guys feel about the
way you voted now i mean it's so obvious
you're asking that yeah i'm asking them
and they're just like oh well you know
no i don't know why don't you tell me
so i think what's happening is that
people are in a position right now
where they are really extremely confused
and the only way to keep them in control
is to be able to push your narrative
down their throat but right now with the
high gas prices with the high taxes with
the open borders
people like whoa did we really make the
right decision so right now
obviously you're not going to get people
from the far right to come to the left
and you're not getting people from the
far left to come to the middle
uh or try to get them to meet in the
middle but you have a lot of people in
the middle
and they're they're like i wonder what
direction to go into
and those are the people right now that
those are the new voting bloc for 2024
and it scares a crap out of cnn the
elite even fox
to think that they may lose these people
because of people they're thinking and
talking freely and i just think that's
where we're at right now
you know because i think a voting block
is opening up right now i really believe
that there's a voting block that's
opening up
i need the far left to come to the
middle a little bit though i need them
to come in
because the thing is they have power the
far right doesn't have power for all
like the boogeyman
far right we're always hearing about
they're not in power no they're not well
who's a far right governor right now no
who who's who's a far what's the far
right
in in you know in in congress and senate
there's the far left is ever increasing
in power yes they own all of our schools
they own all of our c-suites right how
many how many corporations we're going
to talk about nickelodeon in a second
how many corporations do
everything they possibly can bend over
backwards for the far right
yeah none of them yeah but it it takes
exactly
one article from huffington post and now
and now
charles you know charles barkley can't
talk about big big old babies out in san
antonio anymore
they own us they own the culture they
own the zeitgeist they're driving the
ship they're at the wheel man so this
whole 50 50
it's both sides thing it drives me out
of my mind i'm not gonna win though
they're not gonna win though i'm telling
you they're not gonna win because
let me let me put it to you this way
here's what history has told us history
has told us
the biggest thing you can take away from
people that brings out okay so think
about it this way
what will bring out the worst in you
what will bring out the worst in you not
the best in you the worst like look
every one of us has a dark dark side
yeah
inside everybody has it my kids have it
you have it my mom my dad
everybody's got it but for some it takes
a lot to get to right yeah for some it
takes a little for some they
are itching for it right what's going to
get the worst out of you
trying to control me okay yeah what
about here same same okay yeah 100 all
right so so let's let's go through them
actually what
kai what would get the worst out of you
actually i want you i want to ask
everybody
dave during my family what's going to
bring out the ugliest side of david out
like you're going to be like hell to the
no
we don't even recognize you who would
folks if you're listening to this i want
to hear from you as well
what what event what what do you lose
what can be taken away from you where
we're going to see the worst out of you
david what's yours
probably some sort of physical harm to
my family okay i agree that's one of
them i'm with you there
are you same place vanessa about
yourself uh yes
if someone tries to hurt my mom i would
go bananas
okay good you see how you went there kai
by the way our emotions have you noticed
we're like we're there right now it's
intense
guy how about yourself are you really
thinking
this isn't a technical question don't
try to act like you don't have a dark
side deep down inside where you wouldn't
flip
if somebody did something to your mom
who's raised you guys incredibly
if somebody did something to your mom no
definitely family
uh i think that'd be one or just
limiting like severely limiting what i
can say or do i think okay
there you go so now so you have to as
you go down the list
so think about you know somebody putting
a muzzle on you
like actually think you can't talk
anymore what are you gonna do
what what what is how do you express
yourself to tell the world who you
really are yeah and that's what they're
doing
people don't realize like there are
certain things you do to others
you you are like creating a monster
soon to be released to the world you
cannot do that and that's exactly what
they're doing right now
it's not like hey you're gonna go out
there and gonna say these guys can't
talk those guys can do you can't say
anything block these guys censor those
guys
you keep doing that over and over and
over again when it comes back on you
it's not going to be a little bit yeah
it's going to be with vengeance it's
going to be
and it's going to be such true believers
that you're going to be
miserable for decades that's the ugly
thing that's going to eventually take
place
what would it take though i mean i i
would have thought the tea would have
been thrown in the harbor six months
into question it's not it's not a
one-year fix though it's not a one-year
fix the problem with something like this
i don't think it's a one-year fix i
think
so you and i spent the whole day with
rudy giuliani last week yes we were at
rudy's place
and you go in how was he with you when
you spend the time incredible incredible
you make your breakfast you brought you
guys eggs you yeah all that stuff coffee
yeah we had a two-hour sit down ended up
being how long
uh he wouldn't let you leave almost four
hours yeah he wouldn't we had a
four-hour conversation with rudy and
we're going in his office
showing all these stories you know his
uncle joe dimaggio all these great
stories that he had right
and we're sitting there talking i told
rudy i said really one of the biggest
challenge we're facing right now is
you know republicans made a mistake same
thing we keep talking about
they made a mistake republicans went
after being rich and leave me alone
democrats went after let me buy media
and let me buy universities it's very
simple he wanted to disagree with you
that he thought about and then he agreed
with you
yes it was a it obviously would cover a
lot of different things working on a
special project right now that we'll be
launching here pretty soon but
but it you know the the right has to
re-strategize
yeah the the thing is this so check this
out ricky
you know that one time i'm hosting a
meeting at yucca valley
okay mario would remember this we're at
yucca valley i don't even know
you know where yucca valley is yucca
valley is right outside of indian wells
which to to
make the world desert yeah palm springs
area okay so
we rented this castle in yucca valley
this guy builds his castle and all he
does is he rents it up okay so we go in
we're sitting we're trying to come out
with our code of honor how to run our
sales office
this has got to be 06 maybe o7 right
and we go then we decide to come up with
the code of honor that everybody agrees
on
one guy guy named phillip says we should
do parliamentary
uh law that's how we should come up with
these rules parliamentary is what
everybody has to agree or else it's not
getting worse you know we started at six
o'clock at night i'm not even kidding
with you we finished at seven o'clock in
the morning
the next day the next day we finished
seven o'clock
the next morning why because there was
no
one voice i said i will never do this
again initially i agreed to said this is
not effective somebody has to be a shot
caller right
you know what's the problem with the
republican party right now who the hell
is the shot caller nobody
who behind closed doors is sitting down
and saying guys this is the strategy
moving forward
the left's got it right doesn't have it
now don't get me wrong they're segmented
right now even the left because they got
the aoc side
yeah they got the liberal side but there
isn't a voice that's bringing people
together saying what's the next strategy
i think i think they're they're i think
you're right but i think
it's it's not because
how can i put this look the the same
reason why the libertarian party is
never going to be any sort of a real
party because you have people who
their entire intention is small
government you can't sell that
you there's two people there's two types
of people that get involved in
government the greedy and the crazy
okay you have people that are either
trying to give money to politicians
because they expect to get something in
return
or you have people that have been so
negatively affected by something in
their life that they're nuts they're
lunatics they're activists
and those are the people that donate
their time so you have people either
there's two
commodities when it comes to politics
you have time and you have money
how much how much time have you ever
donated to a political party you're
you're a politically active guy how much
time have you ever donated i've dated
quite a bit okay yeah you're in this
entire office
statistically speaking you would be one
of two people in this entire office that
has donated time to a political party
donating money is something even less
people do yeah so
i've done that as well in an office of
100 people the crossover is incredibly
high it's over 75
of the people who donate time donate
money it's a very very active small
group this is the exact point i mean
the more time is given than money more
time is given but the people who give
time also give money it's a 75
crossover very very small group so those
groups tend to be on the extreme so you
were talking about the center before and
how the center there's there's a chance
for a third-party patch tournament yeah
there there's a market for it right now
seven seven over 73
according to the cato institute we fall
between like five and six percent
left and right we're all in the center
we're just the shade of left or shade of
right
right but those people us in the middle
we don't donate our time
we don't donate our money so we don't
get anywhere we don't get anywhere
there's not rally anymore so if you look
at aoc and you look at you know people
that are on the far left and pat you're
talking about where there's no
there's no leader they have nothing to
bribe people with aoc comes in
and she says government is good we need
more government so if you
if you stump for me i'm gonna give you a
job and i'm gonna give you money
and it's not hypocritical because that's
her entire worldview so she can
literally
sell government and people can get
behind and say there's something in this
for
me they can they can hit the ego aspect
of this
if you're a true quote-unquote
republican if you're a true you know
small government conservative
if that even exists anymore if you're
not just a you know a big government but
different type of uh
you know loans to other people right if
you're a true small government person if
you are a true
free market individual it's very very
hard to get people
involved in your cause because there's
nothing in it for them outside of
ideological agreement
right right so that that becomes the
struggle the struggle becomes what's the
carrot
what is the carrot for you i need people
on my campaign
what's the carrot for you i'm gonna i'm
gonna eliminate this department there's
gonna be no giant
for you you know you know it's crazy uh
uh uh kai who what's that one book we
read the guy who
ran washington four years what's his
name uh james baker
james baker the third okay great guy
great story right
they called him the real president of
the united states for a longest time jim
baker james baker you know
but it's the same guy right is that the
guy from the christian group
uh i don't know i don't know if that's
the guy he was a guy that was a
right-hand guy for a lot of people who
won elections okay he's the chief of
staff or i think reagan he was he was
pretty much he was pretty much dick
cheney pre-dick cheney
but he ran everyone right there's only
one thing he had no aspirations to
become which is what lead dog
when i ask joanna mendez the chief
disguise officer of us
i said what's the quality of a great cia
agent she said somebody that's ambitious
charming charismatic yes
all of that except somebody that doesn't
want or need
the credit if they save the world yes
that's what it is this is what they
described the mafia boss
but that's the point somebody who is
the person that needs to be a voice on
the right to help with these strategies
is somebody that has zero aspirations
to be a president zero they have no
aspirations to be president they have no
aspirations to go out there and get
whatever else they need to be doing
it needs to be somebody with credibility
it needs to be somebody that wants to
purely keep it free
if somebody like that gets there and
says hey here's some strategies this is
what i suggest we do
let's get behind this message let's do
something like this let's put a pool
and we create a fund and that fund goes
one by one by one buying any media
company that's on sale i'm going to keep
saying this until somebody
listens to this every media company that
goes on sale you buy it and you pay 25
more you got to compete in the
information economy you have to compete
in information economy
anything new york times for sale buy it
new york post for sale
buy it huffington post for sale buy i
don't care what it is
buy it and pay 25 percent higher can't
beat them buy them i like it
absolutely and you got the fun to do
take the top 100 riches republicans on
the right
take it absolutely create a fund
everybody chips in ten percent you know
it's like i'm gonna give 10 to charity
this isn't charity okay why aren't you
on anybody this makes a ton of i don't
know why they're not doing you know what
you know what
here's here's we were interviewing uh uh
teddy groudie ted gowdy or gowdy uh trey
gowdy trey gowdy
trey gowdy and uh bundy
and so t said uh gowdy or graudy trey
yeah you're saying it right white
people's name is so hard
extremely hard syllables and so
we're interviewing him uh actually one
of my mentors jose gaither
yeah trey gowdy so anyway he's
interviewing him
and trey gowdy kind of he what he does
is he he goes into a a
part where he's very briefly says that
he retired
or he stepped away because he didn't see
what he was rallying going anywhere he
was and he was a
the second to him would be um i can't
remember his name um
i can't remember his name he was really
loud um starts with the jack i can't
remember his name god i love him too i
love watching him i believe trey gowdy
never lost the case as a process right
he never
what i'm getting at is this that the
ones that do want to rally and want to
start a campaign
to get people to wake up to what's going
on
are not having enough backing no he quit
so they get tired he quit
yes specifically because he's like i can
do more good outside right because
imagine that you can't
like going back to pat's point is that
the fact that he
there's no backing he's the perfect guy
for that by the way he
it look it's so funny i haven't even
thought about that yeah he would be the
right guy 100
he would be because everybody trusts him
yes bring him in he has no motive his
motive is he says like it's going to be
my kids i want to my wife doesn't want
to get into politics
but he's a brilliant strategist beyond
closed doors it's it's important
if i ever need it it's important for me
to note gentlemen for the for the
hundreds of thousands of valuetainers
listening that uh ron paul was right
about everything
he's always been right about everything
he's not been wrong
he's been vindicated he was right about
it all well we're going to see what's
going to happen there but let me
let's go to a complete different story
here let's go to uh
papa papa i'm gonna go to the investment
banker labor crunch go to page three go
to page three we'll talk a little bit
business here so
uh invest investment banking labor
crunch a junior banker
shortage is forcing rainmakers to do
grunt work and firms are lowering the
bar
for new hires business insider america
is facing labor shortages
spanning multiple industries banking
isn't immune just months after junior
bankers rallied
against management amid crushing levels
of burnout one of the root
drivers of the problem has yet to be
solved banks have too few hands on deck
to handle their massive deal loads
as a result some senior bankers have
been forced to roll up their sleeves
to work on deal processes that typically
would have been relegated
to the most entry-level employees
according to some banking insiders in
some cases the situation has gone to
dire the banks have been
have had to turn away business some
firms have easily
shed junior throughout the band which
have which have heavily shed juniors
throughout the
pandemic have recently been laterally
hiring juniors with minimal experience
who have a pretty steep learning curve
so
can you imagine saying oh my gosh we
have so many deals we have to
we have to turn them down yeah what a
place to be
what a place to be what do you think
about that story pay people more money
and they will work
my god am i supposed to feel bad for
investment banking firms now that they
can't get cheap labor
for you come on uh enough already with
these guys my god i i am so s dude i'm
so sick of of wall street and the crony
capitalism man
look i i lost a lot of money on uh on my
stunks
when robin hood decided that they
weren't gonna let the hedge fund lose
all right i'm one of those guys that i
got crushed in that in that short
squeeze we were about to make a ton of
money
and they got together with old janet
yellen they said no no no we're not
we're not gonna let we're not gonna let
that that uh that hedge fund go under
we're just gonna shut down
you can sell your stuff but you can't
buy it but you can't buy i can't buy it
yeah
screw that and screw these people all
right you want people to work
pay them you want people to do the job
so really really well
paid people at these firms are crying
because they don't want to do this work
because it's hard then pay people more
money to do the hard work yep
enough already i'm so sick how much of
it has to do with the fact that they're
getting paid to do nothing
which ones what the what the seniors
yeah yeah they like
the junior bankers how much of it has to
do with that well you talking about the
stimulus that they got talking about the
fact that they got the
the seniors are overpaid that's what i'm
saying with the combination of
the fact that stimulus check was
literally almost damn near six figures
dude
how much do you have to do yeah there's
this idea that people are supposed to
quote unquote do the right thing like
don't take the unemployment and go back
to work
screw that man if the government's
giving that money to all their buddies
you take that money too i have
absolutely zero zero problem
with somebody staying home and taking
off the government dime
if they're gonna give this money to
raytheon they're gonna give this money
to their own donors anyway
get yours man because otherwise i said
it last time if you're doing the right
thing
when everybody else isn't doing the
right thing you're not noble you're a
sucker
get cake sit home and cake man if they
want these people to work pat
if they want these people to work sell
some of those da vinci's that they got
hanging on in
the in the 118th floor of their mahogany
offices
and pay these dudes some money pete pay
people to work and they will come back
to work let me give you i
uh kai who do i sit there sit with this
week who told me the story about the guy
that replaced the wework ceo
uh adam uh uh uh adam newman but the
the new guy can you pull up the new ceo
of uh the new ceo of uh wework who's the
new ceo i got the best story i got we
work ceo
i just i just don't have it in me i
can't cry let me tell you this story
uh so i'm speaking to a guy i don't know
what would i interview this week kai who
was the person i interviewed this week
uh business person i interviewed anyway
so i'm interviewing this guy and he
brings up the story of sandeep
and sandeep takes over we work
okay and he uh uh this this one guy is
shadowing him i wish i
could remember who i'm talking to this
one guy's shadowing him around him
oh peter tunney i'm with peter tony
who's an artist out of a wynwood
great artist love the work he's coming
to my house right after this
i got i've got something i commissioned
he's coming out to do something he's
done stuff for michelle obama for jared
kushner for trump for everybody for
bezos everybody's got his piece
he's got a ridiculous he used to be
investment back back in the days very
interesting guy says
at 14 years old i went to a party and we
were there was pot there was cocaine
there was everything there
he said i left the party at 45 years old
that's what he said
the guy's filled with stories so we go
to his place and this weekend i go and i
take shonda and i take
mario and i think sam we go there anyway
he tells a story about
his friend from wework sandeep took over
and he's got a good relationship with
him
he says pat let me tell you how this guy
did it he did it right
he says sandeep comes to want to save
wework
and they asked he said i asked him a
question how did you save it he said
very simple
this is what i did he says i live in a
two-bedroom place
okay he says i drive a volvo volvo he
says one of my top
guys that's making all the money he's
doing all this stuff they don't want to
go to work anymore they're just kicking
back again the problem senior brokers
they don't want to get to work they've
already earned it like i don't
i'm too good this happens in our
business as well ricky where people make
it
and they feel they're too entitled to go
run an appointment and meet with
somebody right six figure golfers
there's no way i'm gonna come sit down
with you who do you think you are like
you realize how much money i make
they kind of start believing their own
hype he says here's what i did
how did you save wework he says i came
in and i knew what my
solution was going to be he said it was
making
2 000 calls a week for one straight year
then i was going to turn the company
around and he says what was the caller
like he just sat there and said he sits
there right in front of his desk
he's got to call him makes a phone call
hey john this is he says i have to make
two thousand six minute calls per month
and i can turn it around within a year
two thousand six minute calls per in a
month and i'll turn the company on
within a year
he calls all the property people that
don't want to pay the rent anymore he's
calling all the people we work he's
calling all the clients
hey so this is sandeep look uh you know
we gotta just wanna call you how are
things what's going on
great fantastic look we got to get that
payment i understand you don't want to
pay it i understand you're going through
struggles but let me tell you something
you got your ppp
you got the the house you're looking at
nobody told you to buy seven uh
you know bugattis nobody told you to go
buy that 40 million dollar home nobody
told you do all that other stuff you did
it
i need that payment to be made and i
need that payment to be made now okay
great
he says that's what i do all day to save
a company
a guy like that in the investment
banking world ends up
gaining so much respect from the street
because he does the work
because he does the work yeah there's a
reason why
he's running we work and replacing adam
newman
and some guy who's out there an
investment banker who's making a senior
broker he's making a million million and
a half he thinks he's already made it
and he doesn't want to go here's another
guy that comes in he's worth a half a
bill this guy's gonna end up being a
half a billion dollar type of guy the
ceo of uh wework right
they're not making the phone calls going
back to the drawing board he says look
running a company is sales you got to
make the phone calls unfortunately in
the world of business many people don't
make the phone calls
i'll tell you ron paul's story and then
we'll go to the next story
i'm sitting with ron paul four years ago
we're in houston
and we were you with us so we're sitting
with ron paul and it was four years ago
and i'm interviewing the guy
and uh what a genius of a his brain is a
very interesting brain right
and he says uh you know years ago i'm a
doctor i think it was a was he was he
there were four thousand babies this was
right after the uh there was that
shooting his son got shot at during
the congressional yeah it was pretty
ugly but but he used to be a doctor and
i think he delivered four thousand
babies i don't know i think it's a four
thousand baby the number that he talks
about
he says one day i hear about this
economist he says so i go while i'm a
doctor i go to hear him speak
and i go once and i go twice i go three
times i go four times he says i keep
going
back to the guy and he tells the guy i
don't know who it was he says i tell the
guy
that look i can't get the stuff out of
my head and i want to tell the world
about it
what do i do ron paul gave the most
ridiculous story
watch what he says he says the guy told
me ron don't worry about it
he says when you believe in a real cause
when you believe in a real cause and
it's not fake and you can't help but
talk about
it it's a crusade you can't help but
talk about it
don't worry the right people will
eventually find you and give you a
platform
wow what a statement right and look at
the guy what he did he raised six
million dollars on myspace
in 24 hours and that became the at 69
years old and everybody realized
raising money is on social media exactly
exactly it stole the whole love and
everything like that i love revolution
he also said something else in that that
was really brilliant
um that he you asked him what the
problem was this might have been off air
while we were setting up the cameras
he asked them you know what what's the
problem with washington like why why
can't people get together
and he said everybody's a lawyer they're
trained to win
oh yeah no he said that that's it he
said that oh they
they don't care if they're right or
wrong they're they're literally trained
winners
right they're trained to win no matter
what it's that's you go to law school
to learn how to win right that's
literally it that's an ago so yeah so
he's a doctor
yeah and then he was describing to you
that there's maybe like four other
businessmen and there's one guy from mit
and then
everybody else is a lawyer so you have
two people then there
they could tell you you know over dinner
like hey look
you're totally right about this we this
is something that we shouldn't do
and then the next day on the floor and
be like we have to do this this is for
america
it doesn't matter they just they're
there to win
and he thinks because they're lawyers
there's not enough of a of a cross
section right uh there's no t
they don't know there's no teachers in
in congress there's no farmers in
congress
there's no entrepreneurs barely
entrepreneurs you know if you even if
you want to count
you know mitt romney i mean he he cuts
people up and chops them in half you
know what i mean he's he's not a he
doesn't build businesses he actually
made his entire career on tearing him
down and parting them out he's a
he runs a chop shop you know what i'm
saying so not that you would know
anything about it
but yeah so i mean that that's that's
part of this interesting thing as well
you know we keep
every time i listen to the podcast and
your valuetainers you know they they
their comments are great and they're
always something to the effect of
everybody wants consensus yeah pat's
always talking about the
left and the right have to come together
the people online respond to that
and it's not that we're like in some
site some sort of
isolated echo chamber where it's like
hey working together helps like every
human on earth knows that working
together is better than than
you know going head-to-head with each
other but there has to be some sort of
examination
of the functions at place that
preclude us from being able to do this
like why can't we get together and this
is one of the things ron paul said that
i thought was really really salient
they're they're lawyers they're they're
not here for consensus you think his son
stands a chance
no he's made too many enemies calling
too many people out
i like i like rand paul i do i like
thomas massey i like tulsi gabbard
you know i like the the the who's the
biggest enemies created is voucher one
of the biggest enemies or no there's
bigger
has to be has to be but remember he he
does the the forensic analysis every
year every year
he goes and filibusters and talks about
uh the dumbest
purchases the government made every year
he goes through the budget and says
you know we spent four hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to what you know to to
uh
for pakistan yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah ten million dollars
although it was one thing they did
something where uh
do beavers have better sex on cocaine
yeah it was like i don't
i don't think we needed to spend 300
thousand dollars watched
his one of his things on youtube their
dad and i was like
we're really studying that those are
kickbacks man those are kickbacks he's
calling out corruption without calling
out corruption
so whoever sponsored those bills is
looking at rand paul going
this [ __ ] nobody would you know
this never happened he's nebraska you
know how they say yeah
uh uh james o'keefe you know you gotta
have brass to be able to do what he does
you know he goes up and you know some of
the stuff
we've heard about behind closed doors
that whatever you know but again for him
to do what he does you gotta have brass
to do that there are certain guys like
him brass gowdy brass uh rand brass
it you don't see tulsi's brass tulsi
tulsi's brass
is so approachable and likeable toasty
has a legs man no i'm sorry
that's a wrong terminology i use you can
use victoria's secret won't have that
sir paul c
gabbard but first of all she's very
marketable very attractive but tulsi has
legs meaning
she can have a career in politics and
actually make some change
in uh the next few decades but going
back to the ron paul story
or the story sandeep the ceo we work the
whole thing is about long-term thinking
you don't you don't make a
change this dramatic in three six months
you got to have a vision
that you sit there and say look guys
we're not really solving for 221 we'll
solve them for 241 2041.
that's how you got to be thinking and i
think 2041 a real shift can be made
go look at the all big influencers right
now bring them together
unite them have a conversation with them
what can we do
if this thing really matters because
there's two things here there's a couple
of things that you got to be thinking
about
one is take the left take the right
there are those who are influencers who
are on the left or the right
that their brand matters more to them
than the crusaders
i don't know if that made sense or not
you know what i'm saying explain that
let me explain it to you
let me explain it to you okay there are
certain people
that wouldn't give up the celebrity
status of who they are
for the freedoms that who they who they
get as a country meaning
they need the credit yeah there needs to
be credits
but i'm doing it but it's me but i'm
doing it if it's really not about the
credit
and if it's really about how much you
want to help save this country well then
come together
well then come together pull it off if
it's really about you want to really
bring everybody together let's bring
everybody together
why don't all of you guys come together
and create a media company to get
everybody owns a half percent a quarter
of a percent one percent
get i'm talking about the big big big
dogs like have millions on top of
millions of followers
go build something together you know pat
uh to touch on that the money's not
gonna be hard to raise no it's not gonna
be hard
but you know what that like to touch on
that point though is that's what
politicon is made for
politicon is made for that and and and
like for example
uh ben shapiro uh offered uh aoc 10 000
debates she won't do it yeah so if you
really believe in what you're talking
about
why aren't these liberals going on there
and actually debating because
they're going to fall apart so i agree
with where you're coming from pat
100 i agree with that the issue is some
people are not showing up to the table
when you're
getting called out but aoc is
low-hanging fruit why didn't he bring on
noam chomsky why didn't he bring on no
no i agree with you
but she's allowed his mouth so if you're
really going to push like she's a little
bit smelly
so you got to go after the loudest mouth
this makes sense so like for example
when trump was president she went to the
border there's a picture of her crying
yeah right okay then
by this president it's climate change
because of the immigration problems
please bro i am begging you please don't
make me defend aoc i thank you
but she did in fairness call out kamala
harris and joe
i agree with you but what i'm telling
you is that she's blaming the border
issue on climate change there's a video
on here on instagram doing that
like this is a hoax this is this is bs
she's got called out so many times
candice owens calls her out right there
you know what i mean so it's like and so
like the whole thing with her
grandmother she oh that that's nice come
on
they're gonna give you a hundred
thousand dollars she made she made a
million and a half off merch because
capitalism's awesome by the way
she makes a million and a half off
merchants my grandma can't eat but
you're gonna blame trump fire an
empanada dark [ __ ]
when puerto rico has been one of the
most corrupt segments uh
america's had for years but because it's
trump
it's just ridiculous so so whatever is
that whenever she gets called out she
doesn't show up the latin american
community not that you can speak for the
entire latin
american of course but it it's very very
interesting to me that
how fervently democrat a lot of them are
but their belief systems
the people that i know like all the way
through and through hard work
faith family you know like that's you
know this is not
exactly it's very simple it's very
simple
the land community only votes democrat
for one
reason and one reason only it's because
they want or they think that voting
democrat
is going to get their pancho to come
over the border and get a job here
that's it when you talk about the actual
views
alignments uh vision of the hispanic
community
has it is the opposite of the democrat
party it is the opposite of the
democratic party but
all you have to do is grab one subject
for example with the black community you
grab one subject which is what is
what's that one second racism yeah with
the hispanics
immigration you got them the rest
they're blinded to one issue
it's a one-issue voter one issue though
though um trump uh put uh the ncaap
on a 10-year on a 10-year plan obama had
it on a year to year funding
though he created the first step act
which released 4 000 prisoners
from non-violent offenses which 75 of
them were black
though the lowest unemployment for
hispanics and blacks were under trump
that's just facts people don't have to
agree facts don't care about your
feelings people i just hope you guys
understand that okay
these are facts right but yeah because
it's [ __ ]
yeah so what i'm getting at is that what
i'm getting at is that
but all you have to do is bring up
racism and you do that
boom everything else goes out the window
yeah but yeah
but so it's like yeah 99 of things one
but
and they'll literally vote for one
person the hispanic community does the
same thing
like i was having a conversation when
hillary clinton pulled out the hot sauce
and yeah
that that that's like that that didn't
win no for example like
and i'm gonna we're gonna move on right
now what what my word
that was that was ridiculous
i love my in-laws like to death right i
shout out to my in-laws i love them they
are they are
like parents i never had right i love
them they they're just the greatest
people
they're just great people right and um
and they're very open to listening so i
when i go to their house i'm hammering
them
and i'm like the tvs i'm like that's
[ __ ] that's a lie
that's [ __ ] like the whole time the
thing is uh
yeah like i'm just throwing [ __ ] at the
tv the whole time i'm like you get some
points treasure channel
right and so they believe me because
they trust me
still and and i'm not against it i don't
want to be one of those i'm not against
it i believe
your body your choice after we told them
and i showed them all the information
on not to get jabbed right
they still when they get jabbed and i
said why if i showed you everything
because the problem pat says this is all
the time it's the last appointment of
the day
their last appointment of the day is
univision it's not me
so i can say whatever i want for seven
hours
the last two hours before they go to
sleep they go to sleep with that in mind
so they want to get jabbed
he's like i just showed you all the
information blood calculations
pfizer's uh bringing you you have to
forgive me i don't watch a lot of
telemundo so is it
like it's it's
it's spanish propaganda it's propaganda
so like for example jorge ramos's
daughter paola ramos
i think her name is paula you're nailing
all these again
so paula ramos if i'm mistaken um she
worked for the clinton campaign so then
you wonder why
i wonder why it's cnn it's spanish
and spanish cnn bro and so what i'm
getting at is that
even having a me in the family even
having a
me the tv has more power over there but
generationally the more men like you
come in set down roots in the country
you're flipping them yeah i'm going to
flip them yeah
let me let me ask you a question let me
ask you a crazy question ready here's a
crazy question for you
all right crazy question i want you to
think about this okay
how many people do you think
you're going to directly or indirectly
flip
in the next 10 years 10 years uh
directly or indirectly flip remember key
is not finding people who agree with you
the key word is flip so so let me let me
i want to ask you the question as well i
want you to think about it as well i'm
going to i'm going to add so
after the new this new um president came
in
um i got and i'm not exaggerating
probably pat about 150 messages from
people that disagreed with me before
and now saw what happened they're like
bro you were right
about everything that you said so i'm
hoping i have actually have a target
number i'm hoping
at least in the hispanic community
within the next 10 years i want to
hopefully influence flip
or start conversations that actually
duplicate i want to flip at least half a
million in the next 10 years
i think you could easily do that yeah i
want to pick a hundred dollars by the
way but you know how big of a number
that is that's a big number yeah you
know how big of a number that is to
remember it's not find a grief flippy
there's a big difference
you may have a million people that agree
with you yes but
900 of them agreed with you 100 000 of
them flipped that hundred thousand is
the key
what do you say how many people you
think you flip or you think you're going
to flip next 10 years i i don't know
i don't know but but what what i what i
try to do especially with my comedy
right is i try to take kind of complex
political issues like we're talking
about now and try to
try to like distill them down for
like everyday people right and and my
big thing i don't know how many people i
want to flip but i just want them to be
aware of the consequences
of the policies so that they support
that's a form of flipping right so
i'll give you a perfect example right so
you know
if somebody says something that should
be illegal okay
a lot of people say well that should be
illegal and they don't understand the
consequence of what exactly they're
saying
so what i'm saying is is like okay if
that should be illegal what you're
saying is
if i do that then a man with a gun
should come to my house and hold it to
my face and say get in that cage or else
i'm gonna kill you
that that's what that is right so like
every new law that we create
i just want people to understand like
okay you're creating an opportunity for
for somebody to say do the same to you
exactly later on and
and i'm gonna i'm gonna kidnap you at
gunpoint i mean really that like
that's what being arrested is being
arrested is the state
kidnapping you at gunpoint now maybe you
deserved it maybe you didn't
but that is what being arrested is be
very very clear
so i try to describe that to people like
being arrested is being kidnapped at
gunpoint
by the state you know what i'm saying so
whatever law we create
like maybe you don't want weed to be
legal you have your reasons for it and
that's fine
but should somebody really be kidnapped
at gunpoint
for having a plant in their possession i
just can't abide by that
yeah right so there's things that should
piss you off i don't think everybody
should be able to come to the barbecue
you know not to get too deep into it but
you know
you kind of talk about my body my choice
before like i think an abortion
is the absolute worst thing somebody can
do i i i personally
am so far against it but i don't think
it should be illegal because it's not my
choice for other people to do what they
do
i agree right and when you make
something illegal i don't think it stops
i think somebody that's that that's the
black market they're gonna do it
themselves and then you create an entire
environment of
you you said the quote what was the the
abraham lincoln quote you told uh
um abraham lincoln quote you gave rudy
it's
do not let um it's the whole industrial
the military-industrial complex that uh
eisenhower had which is they used
communism against anything else which
means
the same things that they fought for
lincoln gave the same thing so obviously
a longer paragraph to read but
it was it was about uh prohibition
doesn't actually stop crime it creates
crime
right creating a prohibition doesn't
stop
the crime it creates criminals out of
people who weren't criminals
and that that's my thing so i i'm kind
of avoiding your answer
you know what that means you know what
he means when he says prohibition of
course you know restricting it you're
stopping and look what happened
they're gonna do it anyways it was
illegal and now like you know how many
people go about
like just the other day you come into
house how much liquor do we have right
now at the house that we have to fill up
the seller the 1500 no honestly how much
you have you you you've got a
nightclub's worth of booze if you see
what's in the house right now right i
would be you would even drink it
i would be arrested 50 years ago for
tomorrow in my house right now foreign
for the rest of your life you got to
understand for the rest of your life
that's the part of like you're taking
people's lives away
especially you talked about non-violent
criminals we talked about russ ulbrich
we talk about
why because he stole money from the
government because the government didn't
get theirs
this this so again i'm not out here to
flip
people i really am not i'm not out here
to flip people all the tolerant liberals
that that you know
that are in your comment section that
every time i say something they they
they don't have an answer for and they
just call me fat you know what i'm
saying like
that's i'm not here to flip them
although i do thank you for your
positive bullying i'm down like 20
pounds so thank you guys
you do look good thank you brother thank
you so thank thank you tolerant liberals
in the comments for
he gave you a shout out yesterday he's
got to know you he's i i guess he could
do four plays but 525 and that's respect
i tear
back 525 but the point i'm trying to
make man is more than anything else i'm
not here to flip well let me give you a
question
what they're advocating from a guy from
the outside that all i look at i like
data and results
that's me that's how i'm driven i like
data and results meaning
uh ben simmons scored five points
yesterday okay he's got to get traded
done doc rivers couldn't answer the
question because he didn't believe it
right
the the philadelphia 76ers should be
going to the finals right now but a trey
young beat him
embarrassing in game seven shouldn't be
happening now durant lost because
he had a teammate that's probably the
worst teammate in the nba which is kyrie
irving he shows up when he wants to
harden was hurt he pulled it by himself
he almost beat milwaukee single-handedly
without any help he did buy himself so
durant is not leaving the playoffs with
anybody giving them criticism durant's
leaving the playoffs
everybody's saying out there everybody's
saying he's the greatest player in the
league today right today right
so data yeah ben simmons guess what you
suck
because your attitude sucks your
attitude absolutely
sucks he has this attitude about himself
that he doesn't have to improve on
anything
that's the biggest challenge with them
this guy could be the next lebron james
this guy could be the next face of the
league but he doesn't think he has any
area to improve it
that's a weakness let's talk data here's
data for you uh historically
who in your life shifted your way of
thinking give me three names who in your
life that you think about
[ __ ] and what part of it say politics
capitalism you wait
in politics and capitalism was you okay
okay give me two other names who in your
life got you to think of certain things
it could be spiritual yeah it could be
marriage it could be finances it could
be
business it could be politic who flipped
you does it have to be
somebody i met or is it can it be
something no no not at all could be it
it could be a distance yeah it could be
a milton friedman i've never met milton
friedman right yeah who who could it be
for who's it for you flipped or just
influence in general
for you to say damn that makes sense you
know what maybe they want to thank you
right
yes yes okay to me for for uh
on a personal level to be a little bit
more careful with my decisions and who
i'm around
i'm gonna say it's gonna be my
grandmother okay she's like very like
hey be aware of who's around you not
everybody's your friend because i used
to be very um
trusting you know very not like trusting
me like you're young and naive so you
think everybody's out to help you
uh with politics and uh with politics
and capitalism obviously it was you
and then um as far as uh uh taking
things a little bit more
uh to a whole other level of um
of uh making a um how can i explain it
uh making it a uh
an actual um career not career but a um
making a bold move in a statement i
think to me is going to be
my buddy jesse with lexi like hey we
really need to push
it's not just you believing in your
perspective on
what's happening with america we need to
drive this to the
jesse jesse from so so from legacy
movement so
pbd yeah jesse graham grandmother yeah
okay who's for you
three names um well i i don't know his
name it's crazy but one of the most
influential moments of my life was that
navy seal gave the speech
uh when i was with the cardinals you
told me that story that's
sick that was that was one of the most
that was like transformative
uh you called it the best motivational
speech you've ever heard and you've
heard thousands
yeah and it tell everybody since they're
listening could be good for them to hear
it
okay um all right so when i when i was
in the minor leagues one of the things
that they
they do is they have these they bring
everybody into an auditorium once a week
i i imagine similar like you know sales
executives
and they give these motivational
speeches and they have these speakers
come in and they get
you know an hour and it's normally
horrible it's normally the worst hour of
your entire week you got to listen to
this guy
you know try hard if you're not working
hard the other guy blah blah blah blah
blah we're like yeah we don't we get
that
like we didn't get here by not working
understanding that
jerk yeah but there was one guy came in
he was navy seal
knowing these guys wear suits and
everything like that this dude was in
t-shirts jeans and flip-flops kind of a
little dude like not like what you would
expect the navy seal or whatever and uh
he stands up and he's like who here has
heard uh pain is weakness leaving the
body and we're like ah here we go again
he's like that is the dumbest [ __ ]
anybody's ever said out loud we were
like what
he was like who here has heard that if
you're not working hard
somebody else is going to outwork you
and when you meet them they'll win
and we were like yeah they were like
yeah because rest isn't important and
like you know if you if you over train
and tear your
tear your knee did your did your acl
lack will
and so we're like what is this guy
talking so the anticipation
unconventional
everything we've ever heard it turns it
is what man he says this is the deal man
he goes this sucks
waking up at six o'clock in the morning
and running and working out and then
going for batting practice all day
and then hitting the gym and that that
sucks
but you do it anyway and you can't trick
yourself
into saying something that sucks doesn't
suck you can't be on the
third mile of a three and a half mile 95
degree run
yeah and be like this is great i love
this no it's horrible
but you do it anyway and everybody else
when it gets horrible
they quit and that's why you're you and
they're them know it sucks
and do it anyway embrace the suck that
was his whole thing
embrace the suck so number one embrace
the suck navy seal who else give me two
more uh two more the second one was
jordan peterson somebody that you've
interviewed very very very influential
in my life and the third one is probably
isn't one person i went into college a
pretty liberal dude very anti george
bush very anti
uh uh blood for oil it was all the
liberals in my college that were doing
like performative stuff and i was like
man i am definitely not one of them
so it's crazy you've told that story
watch this year so watch this here
he just gave his three you gave your
three navy seal jordan peterson uh
liberal
liberals at the college you went to a
bunch of people by the way i'm curious i
want to hear you or somebody
some people are saying they got a list
here so i'll give you some of the names
jordan peterson
uh uh is out here by a lot of people
uh rogan pbd jordan peterson larry elder
trump
uh prophet muhammed a guy
said nice annas that's interesting
tim cast mom brother-in-law you're
hearing already listen
friedman reagan thomas soul uh uh
uh so anyways you're going through david
goggins tony robbins all these names
right when you sit there and think about
it
um i would have to say
my three i would put milton friedman in
that list
okay 100 milton friedman's got to be on
that list for me
um i would put
i'm trying to say milton friedman would
be one uh
uh i'd have to put uh ein rand on that
list
with atlas shrugged yeah i would have to
put that on the list
um there's a there's a guy named mano
that most people won't even know the guy
played a very important role even though
something
stuff happened to him he was a very
important guy for me m-o-n-o
m-a-n-r meaning guy we used to go to his
place and we would sit there from friday
nights every friday night for about two
years from six o'clock to two o'clock in
the morning
we debated uh religion and politics is
what we did
wow and from six p.m to two in the
morning with myself
it was myself armond uh uh
the owner of this place yeah he would go
he introduced me to him by the way
our men who ended up committing who took
his life and a couple other things
stories that we had that we go there
anyways so these guys flip me but
you know example why it's that but
flipping is different there's an example
there's a flip i'm talking flipping
flipping is you're sitting you're like
damn i never thought about it that way
before right
i never thought the art of flipping
is not people who are extremely loud
emotional that's not you are flipping
no very subtle obama flipped people yeah
and he did it in his own way obama did
obama got republicans to say
this guy's not that bad let me vote for
this guy he's a flipper okay
trump flipped people like him or not he
flipped people
yep he got some people to say i like
this guy bill clinton
flipped people reagan flipped people
reagan when he won and the day of
inauguration
romania sends all the different pows 30
minutes after he's given his speech
and he says this happened because of
jimmy carter he didn't take the credit
so he got the democratic audience to say
[ __ ] how do you not like this guy man
freaking give them credit
to the guy he just beat you gotta love
this guy right
he flipped people the art of we need
more people today
who are learning how to flip instead of
talking to people like they're idiots
nobody flips when you think the audience
is an idiot
not on the left not on the right the art
of flipping people is not
what an idiot what makes they're not
going to flip like that there's got to
be completely different way to
presenting an argument to a person to
say
you know i never thought about that
that's the key what you just said
presenting an argument having an actual
real debate it doesn't happen now it's
all canned
debates that's really just propaganda
it's really just
their message in the form of a
quote-unquote debate
but nobody's having these conversations
these open and honest conversations you
know like
and there has to be some sort of it's us
too we got to check ourselves as well
like we have to allow
ourselves to be open to that new
information as well right like it can't
just be like
you know what what's uh you said
something once that was really really
smart pat and it was it was something to
the effect of
too many people listen to talk they
don't listen to hear right like i think
and that that's the truth yeah and i i
do that as well as well
like i i'm as guilty of that as anybody
it's like especially when i'm in a
debate
i think it's human nature to want to do
that you have to you know that's
something i love about rogan
rogan for for whatever people say about
rogan and for some reason the left
absolutely hates rogan now but
you know he legitimately listens to
every guest he has on and he takes in
the information and he says okay he
tries to do
this how do you not love a guy like that
how do you know he's so necessary that's
when he asks brian stelter
but you have to realize guys the truth
of the matter is with brian stelter and
broken here's what happens guys
you have to understand how the game of
competition works
one of the best quotes i ever read about
parenting which my uh
dudley rutherford told me was the
following he says parenting fatherhood
goes through three phases
it's you first idolize oh my gosh my
dad's my hero like my sons are in the
idolizing phase right now okay they
think i'm the greatest thing since
sliced bread i'm not naive because you
know what's next phase demonization
it's demonized it's like oh my gosh this
guy's a freaking worst father of all
time
leave me the hell alone stop and i'm
just so sick and tired of this
and then you humanize so you know what
freaking hey this guy seemed right
yeah it's my pops like you know he's not
perfect i'm not perfect
you kind of go through that phase right
competition goes through the phase as
well
except the competition they first laugh
at you then they violently oppose you
then you become self-evident right
it's very simple you cannot you can
violently oppose
anybody that's coming up in every
competition this happens
they violently upon the trey young he's
not he's not the next steph curry
about 70 rookie cards of trae young the
month of the pandemic
a guy needed money because the market
took a hit he said i'm dropping 70.
i said dude i'll pay you what do you
want to do you soldiered me for nothing
i made 4x on the money i bought 70
rookie cars psa 10 of
trey trey young i said trade gotta trey
young right oh there's no way in the
world
and he has to go out there and say well
this guy's a baller he's each one and
then you hear all the comments we always
knew he was a baller dude he didn't say
he's a baller you said this guy's gonna
choke
but he showed up in the fourth quarter
hit the three when it was necessary even
though he's five
four four twenty two he hits that three
right you are going to go through that
phase
right now you know what you know what
status rogan has earned it's a very
unique status and that's the status
everybody fears the
competition fears and they want to
destroy
the last status you get to is saint
status
you know what saint status same saint
saints yeah of course
saints you know what saints said he's
wrong you're untouchable you're
untouchable rogan is saint status
he's saint status well then why spotify
taking all of his uh podcasts they can
do why is he letting him
they can do whatever they want to do to
the guy he's saying status the only
problem with saints
here's the only problem with saints you
know what's the problem with saints they
were once sinners
so the opposition can always go and find
a bunch of dirt on them and they're
willing to pay premium to bring it out
to trash them so just wait the next two
three four five years
on strategies on track i'm telling you
right now
rogan doesn't walk on water broken who
he is today is because he's made
mistakes and he becomes
the person who has a lot of perspective
at his level i
guarantee you that person's made a lot
more stupid mistakes behind closers that
a lot of people don't know about then i
hope he owns it man because you know
what i don't think anybody wants
somebody perfect anymore we we're in the
era of office
but but i think i think i hope
he's got such a big loyal following yeah
around him
that they're gonna come look when he
gets to a point where
you know you're a person that's a tiger
pat it's like who like tiger woods
yeah but this is different because the
difference with tiger tiger
tiger was there was an element of tiger
that i'm 10 times better than you rogan
doesn't think he's better than you yeah
sure
doesn't have that energy just like dude
i don't know what the [ __ ] rogan says i
don't even know what i'm talking about
i'm just kind of all from grace for but
for tiger tiger's like yeah um
he's 20 years old doing an interview he
says what's your goal to win 19 majors
to be the greatest of all time tigers
saying this at 19 20 years old i mean
that's
you know you know that's a little bit
even jordan said
look i don't know what the argument i
don't know where i'm at that's for the
critics to make the feedback but i think
i'm in the argument right now
i think if you want to make the argument
with me against magic all the i think
i'm finally i'm in the argument right
now if you want to involve me
so there was that element with it right
right right i think rogan is insane
status but uh
media is gonna find stuff yeah it's very
easy to send money and say can you tell
me something so guess what direction
they're going to go they can't go drugs
because he openly talks about drugs
the only thing they can go through is
what women touched women or something
like that
they're going to try to do a uh what's
that one uh comedian
uh uh yeah the one cavanaugh no no no
not cavanaugh the comedian the comedian
who
was uh um we talked about him all the
time louis ck
right they're going to try to find
something yeah the thing is louie louie
did do that though i'm not saying he did
that i'm not saying he's going to find a
video of me
but they waited 10 years until yeah so
just listen
if it happens don't flip and be
surprised
people are going to find out that this
is a flawed man like anybody else you
don't earn saint status being a
i saint think it's the audience it's
always you know the problem is it's it's
the company that bails
it's the people on top it's going to
have a place that pulls that's how you
have a place
yeah he will always have a place
broken's always going to have a place
and by the way the part with rogan
that's absolutely genius
he's always confusing his audience and
here's how he does it
you know what i think i'm going to vote
for bernie sanders bernie sanders
thanks joe for the you know confidence
i don't know if i'm going to vote with
bernie sanders i like this guy i'm going
to go to this uh you know joe jorgensen
which
who would vote for them yeah i think i'm
going to go
she's awesome i don't say she's not
awesome but it's not a it's not a
marketer
a joe jorgensen to me is someone behind
the scenes that
coaches are libertarian on how to go out
there well not the face she's not a face
spike cohen her vice president pretty
much agreed with you because he took
over her campaign people actually
thought
despite cohen was the guy who was
running for yeah listen the last two
libertarian candidates are absolutely
you know
terrible marketers anyways but we got a
surprise guest here
let's get a friend here is uh our friend
here who i'm trying to get this guy to
liquidate
i'm trying to get him to lift weights i
don't know why he doesn't hit the gym
when are we hitting the gym then i can
tell him
oh my gosh we got phil in the house
so yesterday phil says he says look when
it comes down to judging you have to be
able to judge on the following different
things he says like look at this
phil goes like this it's 12 30 of that
he says look at the skin look at this
you can't judge that how you doing man
how you feeling i'm great
yeah did you hear the opening about the
the
you know my uh taking shots at mr
olympia or now you didn't hear that part
at the beginning so i don't want to get
you in trouble
just so if if anybody from the olympia
brand is listening he is
he is not in agreement with me this is
me saying it i'd stand for my opinions
he has his own opinions
but uh it's good to have you in florida
no thank you it's great to be here
yeah how's it how's it feel now being in
florida how are you doing
i think i need a change yeah yeah i
think i'm excited to hear more about the
change yes
and i think a lot of people are curious
to know what that change is
but we we know the change but some
people don't know the change but it's
going to be exciting to talk about the
change absolutely
for the right time when the right time
comes we'll talk about the chat do you
have any idea what the hell they're
talking about
i have no idea i'm just here pretending
like i know what they're talking about
oh my gosh yeah so it's uh it's uh we
were just right now we were just right
now what happened
mike put it closer okay we were just
right now
uh and by the way got to tell you you
broke even though how long has it been
since uh you competed
september no december december december
18th birthday mm-hmm
right on your birthday yeah that's used
to do you still look really good yep
yeah seventh time man you thinking crazy
yeah crazy to have that going on but uh
what do you want to say man what do you
want to say to people what's on your
mind right now
oh right now i mean obviously we're
living through an interesting time yep
and uh i will use one of your lines and
say that the future is very very bright
and especially for those people who know
how to respond
to the call of action right now and they
have to figure that out for themselves
but they
once they figure out that why and dig
deeper and deeper and deeper
almost to where emotions come out they
can then
develop those strategies necessary for
their own level of personal greatness
and i you know i've been traveling
around now and i've been meeting a lot
of different people and they've
been feeling the same way so i'm really
encouraged to you know spread more
positivity to everybody letting them
know that you know with the world
opening up especially in america with
gyms
thank goodness because a lot of people
are dealing with their mental health
that you know they just really have to
stay positive and
you know continue the good fight yeah i
mean that's that's the
one big thing when uh by the way one
story i have here the story was uh
that uh the shutdown did you see that
story the week which story is uh
did you put the story up what the
lockdown did yeah there you go harvard
data matter of fact i'm just going to
read that right now since you brought
that
five go to page five page five i think
this is a story that phil just kind of
brought up right now new harvard data
accidentally reveals how lockdowns crush
the working class while leaving
elites unscathed right this is a
foundation for economic education new
data analysis from harvard university
brown university and the bill and
melinda gates foundation calculate
how different employment levels have
been impacted during the pandemic today
defining
the findings reveals that the government
lockdown orders devastated workers at
the bottom
of the financial food chain but left the
upper tier actually better off it's
interesting that the lockdown was to
protect
the bottom but it actually ended up
hurting the bottom is what it did the
analysis examined
employment levels in january 2020 before
the coronavirus spread wildly before
lockdowns orders and
other restrictions on the economy were
implemented it compared it compared them
to unemployment employment figures
from march 31st 2021 here's the data
employment for
lower wage workers defined as earning
less than 27 000
a year annually declined by a whopping
23.6
over the time period employment for
middle class wage workers defined as
earning between 27 to 60 grand
declined by four and a half percent
however employment for high-wage workers
defined as earning more than 60k this is
not even millionaire by the way
above 60k actually increased 2.4 percent
over the measured time period despite
the country's economic turmoil
the data's are damning they offer yet
another reminder that government
lockdowns hurt most
those who could of at least afford it
when you talk about gyms i can't even
tell you how many people were calling
saying where the hell do i go to work
out
our office had a gym people who had no
gym had gym memberships other places
that were shut down they were coming to
the office to work out on the weekends
at our office in dallas i mean hell i
didn't have a gym
you know getting ready for the olympia
luckily i was able to sneak in with a
key
and literally had to train with the
lights off and parking down the street
so that no one could see me
you know training during the day or at
night my question would be how can i
look like you without needing a gym i
think that's a good question everybody's
he just implicated himself in a felony
as well by the way thanks for that yeah
yeah
gerard you look like you want to say
something about this oh man i should let
everybody else go first because i feel
pretty strongly about this one
tell us tell us what you do look this is
this is endemic of a a wider societal
issue
the the elites have are so far gone
they're so far gone from the reality of
everyday life
you know this is these are people that
you know when they were shutting down
the coal mines they were like well just
learn how to code
why don't these guys just learn how to
code man they're 45 years old 50 years
old they've been working in a mine for
20 years and you're like yeah just
just go to devry and learn how to code
get a job in it they
work remotely these are people with
high-paying six-figure jobs that all
they need
is high-speed internet and they can work
from aspen and they're like well
who cares if i don't have to go to an
office they don't think about
the office building supports the dry
cleaner down the block supports the
pizzeria down the block
the barber down the block there's an
entire ecosystem
that is around supporting them the
high-wage earner
but they've been they've spent their
whole life going to private schools
going to you know these high-end ivy
league universities and then they go to
these google campuses
they've never been around quote-unquote
normal people
you know this is where you get this gal
gadot you know and all these hollywood
elites thinking they're going to cheer
us up during
the quarantine like you know singing
that song imagine like we're in this
together guys
and it's malibu in her backyard with a
20 000 square foot house and i'm sitting
in here
in a one bedroom in jersey city above an
indian restaurant going out of my mind
like
we are in this together we are not in
this
you sing one more time i am going to oh
same thing i got a tillage gym in jersey
brother bro
they shut down the gems and the churches
during a pandemic so we can't be healthy
spiritually emotionally or physically
but they kept the liquor stores and
burger king open man
like come on bro this is what i'm
talking about this is a let them eat
cake moment this is why i
love gerard i love data so
i brought billy bean to one of our
events i don't know what it was two
years ago or two years ago i said two
years ago i brought bill
to mgm yeah but we only did it at the md
meeting was only the brokers mean it
wasn't for everybody right and i'm
interviewing uh billy bean he says you
know when you're winning
you love data when you're losing you
hate looking at the numbers because it's
not the numbers fault
it's it's something else it's you know
it's this it's that it's this right it's
never the you know it's
no there's a whole story behind it right
okay
you can get up there and talk about
everything you want about the right
decisions we made etc etc
then comes data and then you have to say
why did florida's
shutdown format work why did
texas work why did why why didn't
california work
why didn't new york work i mean within a
span of a week we were both in new york
and in california
right new york everywhere we're going
we talked to the cab driver cab driver
was like no we felted the shutdown half
a million people have left this place
california we go there
mario and i are at uh i don't know where
we went we went to get this uh
food by the water this guy runs up stop
stop stop stop stop put the mask on
completely different environment that
they got but
phil the the gym the fitness world
you're in that space
how big of a hit that they take you know
like now it's
after pandemic how big of a hit have
some people taking did some people fully
get out of the business
there's a lot of gems that suffered no
question about it and um
unfortunately those personal trainers
they suffer tremendously
because they can't even the ones that do
like online workout programs
they're working from home but they also
are working internationally
so imagine not just the people who they
can help domestically in the united
states
but overseas they still don't have gyms
so a lot of the personal trainers are
like well what do i do how do i really
pivot
and even those influencers that are like
you know you got bodybuilding and
influencers
kind of mixed together what are they
going to do just home workouts all the
time eventually that became boring
and it became very i would say
disingenuous to say that
i got my physique based on this so a lot
of people
had to really just take a hiatus and a
lot of athletes
were furloughed like crazy a lot were
let go
contracts from the supplement companies
i mean supplement companies
i mean they all lost their ass
tremendously
so they're just now starting to
i say turn the corner a little bit
but i think uh those people that
are turning it are probably watching
valuetainment
and learning how to be a better
businessman you know to understand that
this may happen again so how do we
you know solve that problem yeah
but the unfortunate problem part is is
that
a lot of them still haven't figured out
like a specific
training module or whatever to enhance
like their
abilities and i know we were talking
about stuff like that last night is that
you have an online course if somebody
wants to learn how you all your secret
stuff that you've done over the years is
there like an online course survive
yours or no
not yet in the process oh bro people
would pay
premium for that to get their hands on
how you train like you don't
have a video that shows how you trained
with a camera showing exactly your
routine
i've had uh workout videos you know dvds
all that stuff
you know i've done collaborations with
different companies but uh
no wow something's coming though well
something like that
i hope so because i know a lot of us
would want to jump are you kidding me
you got a seventh time who is still
who is still in shape like you can
compete this year if you wanted 100
any plans of this year or no uh you know
my phone's still on
my phone still works my phone still
works
i don't know if those guys have called
you or not the folks from uh this uh
what is the brand called mr olympia
right yes you still play basketball phil
2k
i mean is this a challenge no no no no
no no no no no no no no
i can't play basketball in my life
but i read your story and i know you
were a basketball player before yeah no
i
i love it but uh you know for me to get
back out there
at you know over 250 pounds it's
difficult right it's not smart yeah
you're asking you're really you're
really asking for a problem i mean
what do you mean what do you mean by
that a problem well for for me i mean
normally i would get up to like 275 i'd
you know off season
right now i'm like at 250. um i had
actually
tore my mcl uh about a year and a half
ago and competed with it
so i'm only imagining like if i decided
to go out and run
oh then i probably wouldn't tear
something else oh so
what is it though is it the is it the
weight is the torque i mean
yeah yeah i mean you gotta get i mean
look like when i played ball in college
i was 175 pounds
right right you know you look it up on
the internet i mean i was pretty darn
lean at the time you were i saw pictures
of you yeah and uh
now you got basically 80 pounds on that
right you're gonna
and much more years right on the on
those joints
plus your muscles grow your ligaments
don't yeah you're just begging for a
problem
oh i see them i see interesting
how's uh um coleman doing he was he was
did he have surgery is that what he was
working with numerous yeah so he's had
numerous surgeries but
you know i i definitely feel like he's
finding his way
yeah he seems a lot one thing i give
ronnie coleman
is his level of positivity yeah
throughout this entire process
yeah i mean i couldn't imagine i mean i
had two hernia surgeries in two years
and i was definitely not happy with my
surgeon right you know at some point
for him to have more than ten wow i mean
and still go to appearances i mean i'd
be doing appearances with coleman
you know overseas and he's standing as
long as he's supposed to be sitting down
in a wheelchair
and this man would you know get up stand
up shake hands with people
listen to their stories for six hours
straight wow
i mean you guys are men of sheer will
there's no way oh 100 percent
yeah oh yeah shout out to staying
positive it's worked well for charlie
sheen
so everybody should big inspiration
big inspiration big inspiration for that
i want to go to a different story i want
to go through a story here
we got about the american dream and i
don't know if you've uh
seen this story or not but if you want
to go go to page
american dream is what page guy is it on
page two it's page two page two
okay go to page two on the bottom how
the two biggest status
symbols of the american dream came to
pose the greatest risk
on inflation crisis business insider
story owning a house
and a car has symbolized the american
dream since the end of world war ii
but these markers of 20th century
prosperity are posing the 21st century
greatest inflation risk
by may a popular gauge abroad price
growth had leaped to its high
highest level since 2008 conservative
economists and lawmakers have raised
fears that unless the government raises
in its spending the u.s risks repeating
the crippling spiral of runway inflation
from 1970s
these months of decade high inflation
driven largely by home and car prices
are now the principal risk
to the economy economic recovery fannie
mae said on a wednesday report
unless bottlenecks are quickly
unalleviated and price growth cools
inflation that's been largely deemed
temporarily by the federal reserve could
plunge in the u.s into a new economic
crisis
the company's economic and strategic
research group said by the way
do you think the owning a house is still
the american dream would you say it's
still an american dream
how how would you what would you say is
the american dream today to you
being an entrepreneur being owning a
business having passive income pay for
all your stuff that's my
that's my the american dream 100 okay so
now go to
go to somebody that's making 80 a year
go to an 80 000
year person like 60 to 80 60 to six
figures you're making 600 200 000
what is the american dream for that
person maybe more than their friends
making more than their friends that's
tough man
i think it's it's moved sorry yeah i i
think it's uh it's regional i think the
american dream is different depending on
where you are
i think the texas american dream florida
american dream is different than the new
york american dream like
and i think it's cultural now too i
think for
some people i think for some people like
having a phd means more to them
than having more money than having yeah
it's actually a very good point
like tim grover uh tim grover's dad or
parents they kind of
suddenly throw shots at the fact that
he's not a doctor you know even though
he the guys
lawyers you know similar to middle
eastern what they say but
i guess i can see that you know for our
boy adam suss i
i hope uh soy man mafia is listening
right now
he's not soy boy folks by the way he's
he's a big strong man
so soy man mafia uh if you're listening
the american dream was a house and a car
and an education
and the government got involved in all
three markets yep and what happened
that's that's all that's all i'm going
to say big government spend tax and
spend adam sauce
great hair horrible politics so if the
government never got involved
1978 community reinvestment he's about
to drop in your dm
it dropped if he never got in yeah you
get shaq in your dms i get sas and mine
we ate the same the uh he remembers when
the whole shack thing happened when uh
the kobe interview when uh kobe i asked
kobe i said what would have shaq been if
you had your work ethic and
kobe said he wouldn't be the greatest of
all time we would have won 12
championships and then shaq got pissed
and came back but uh well you told us
that you actually never shared that
story with us
about shaq getting what he told you we
know that there was backlash because
espn on that but you never know
shaq dm'd me yeah he was furious saying
that you know yeah he says
who you know who are you to ask a stupid
question like that you know from kobe
who would i have been if i would have
had a work ethic you don't even know
what you're talking about and it just
blocked me i'm blocked from shack on it
[Music]
i would love to sit down shaq will be
surprised if he sits with me because
if you see my my go ahead how many papa
john's
franchises do you have to buy before
shaq no i i
i actually i actually by the way the
field message check and phil's like
because phil and shaq have done stuff
together shaq is a big
fan of phil's work shaq would come to
watch phil uh at mr olympia i think you
guys have had uh multiple interactions
together
yeah so but i remember oh you messaged
him
no no he sent a tweet out because of
what happened back in fort shack was
pissed
but if if we play you know the game pick
your starting five and i said you got
first pick you pick mj
my second is you know i'll go let you
say lebron or something like that
and then your third pick is going to be
let you say you pick kareem i'm picking
shaq
yeah i pick shaq because shaq is
irreplaceable we talked about them last
night
i've never in my like i watched i've
watched lebron i've watched jordan i
watched bird matt i've never
seen anybody just decide you know what
no i'm just gonna score the next 50
points
and just like i've never seen anybody
complain again
like 2 000 what are you gonna what are
you gonna do about it try to stop me
like that was his mindset
try to stop me anyway so yeah so going
back to this whole thing with american
dream yeah i think you're right it's
different based on culture it's
different based on zip code it's
different do you have a different
opinion
what he just said no no i agree with
them i know with us with the hispanic
community it's
it's very much just as long as you can
pay your bills and uh buy your little
house and then you're good
like to the american dream to the
hispanic to this day is still
buy a house like if you could you could
stay american you could own
yeah you can own a hundred units pat you
can own
a skyrise in the middle of la you don't
own a house you're not crap in the
hispanic community
house and uh scores yeah score yeah oh
my that's big on that my that's fico
scoring don't get any tickets don't know
the government
yeah but in hispanic communities you
could own every you could have every
house in the block except yours you're a
loser
literally people will flex on instagram
yeah and say
you know my fico is this this is yeah
and uh
i'm thinking well yeah mine's mine's
been up and mine's been down and i still
have the better credit card ability to
spend so
you know you just have to it's not
buying power by the way that makes
you powerful in the hispanic community
it's the fact that you own a house or
you have a high fight it's always been
like that though
even where i grew up well my dad met
siamek for the first time yeah okay and
siamek is coming to ask my dad for his
daughter my sister right and we're
sitting and we're like oh my gosh here
we go
this is gonna be so weird my dad asks
him what's your credit score
my dad asks young like what is your
credit score she looks like excuse me
dude the world needs your dad on the
podcast he is coco
david joey coco david needs to come on
the podcast you and him have had some
conversations together guys
by the way we had a guy just gave 500
right now norman j
i think that's the highest ever i tried
to comment earlier in the podcast but i
had to verify the transaction on my cc
active listening uh listen for
understanding not to respond we learned
this is military leadership training
he's got his website there
www.njsdcapital.com i am a newbie
entrepreneur and i want to attend the
vault conference
and get on that yacht it's a must norman
send us a text at three one zero three
four zero one one three two
three one zero three four zero one one
three two we'll have one of our guys
contact you
uh but that's the record right there
we've ever had so hey thank you for that
donation man it's
but we'll have one of our guys contact
you listen to that in the super chat pat
if they give a thousand dollars in the
super chat phil will take his shirt off
and flex
and if they give 2 000 i'll put another
shirt on and walk out the room
watch somebody put a thousand dollars
right now but the thousand dollars going
straight to phil if you do that because
this would be like a uh a uh what do you
call it
uh you know how you go to events and
you're doing it yes posing yeah
so so uh uh so okay let's continue here
what else we got on stories that we
haven't covered what else we got on
stores that we
the nickelodeon the nickelodeon one
nickelodeon oh you know what like you
know what were you doing
did you do this by the way dude did i do
this on purpose
no no no no this is a great friend this
is tiffany
oh i see what you're saying oh you're so
funny buddy
you are so funny that was watermelon
watermelon george's having a blast
you know like i follow daniel d martino
booth and i'm looking at this and i'm
like
we're screwed oh it's a lot of people
it's about to be it's about to be
explosive it's about to get very ugly
and by the way here's
the biggest thing is when a person who
is saying their entire lives i work for
you my policies to make
your life better but your policies
temporarily hurt
him or her but two three years down the
line destroyed that person's livelihood
there's only a matter of time before
those guys say i don't know if your
policies are really that good for
me you're just hoping the folks on that
end are not not naive enough to just say
i think they're going to do it next time
i think they're going to do it next
month i think eventually people are
going to be like i'm not going to do
this anymore
you've not done anything for my life
california california
colorado jersey in florida
all right like there's a reason why
we're all here don't forget norway
norway yeah by by way of uh california
by way of california
and a baby seal he wrote it all the way
here
but the this is the thing and again to
bring up adam right like adam
was like with a lockdown's really that
bad he's been in florida the whole time
like like you don't know like like it
sounds so cliche to say this but you
don't know what we went through
like i was a legit political hostage
like i literally have
none essential can you show that people
people think that's like not real that's
a real tattoo
non-essential tattooed because they
they shut me down they shut dude i was
on him not one
i was on two national tours all right
thousand dollars a show not that anybody
needs to know my finances
70 shows x out gone 70 shows
then i go back home to jersey the
highest taxes in the damn country
and they tell me because i work
nationally i'm ineligible for
unemployment
so i've been paying taxes in new jersey
i can't get unemployment they won't let
me
work i'm seeing strip clubs and liquor
stores open
strippers are essential but i'm not i'm
watching wwe on tv and i'm like
these damn bodybuilding stunt men
nowhere fans don't get me wrong but i'm
like these dudes are essential
and i'm not like i'm watching these
dudes dropping rock bottoms on each
other
and i'm like these guys are essential
and i'm anybody that's essential during
the
pandemic is comedians yeah dude if
there's anybody not essential brother
so i'm saying at 70 70 grand 18
months of my life they locked us in they
locked us indoors like it was literally
illegal after 10 o'clock for us to go
outside
like you had to show your papers like
what are you doing out here why ten
o'clock
dude because the coronavirus is a
motorcycle gang and it comes out at
night
that's why that's why
all right because why why did we have to
wear our mask
into into bro don't even get me started
on the flight back on the flight back
this just happened on a fight back from
san francisco
this woman she had it out for me man
she was like checking me if my mask was
here instead of here she was like sir
i've asked you to put your mask out i
was like lady
when you were passing out the crackers
five minutes ago the entire plane
took our masks off at the same time we
were sitting next to each other
unmasked naked face next to each other
for five whole minutes i think if
anybody had anything it's been
transmitted
can i please can i please told her that
yes did they kick you off the plane
she got mad at me then she came back
again when it was here and i was like
say it from six feet away if we're gonna
if we're gonna follow
you i swear to god hand to god i was
like get six feet away if we're
following the rules we're following all
the rules and we'll follow the rules
we'll follow
them all say it from six feet away what
did she say
what you saying she backed up she was
like
but i was like
you should have gone like this yeah
dying
and nobody needs sky waitresses anyway
but i want to know
but i want to know what data shows that
the amount of people who get hypoxia by
wearing it
because what's hypoxia you never been to
denver
no like high altitude and all that stuff
so like for instance like like
breaking ridge you go there it takes you
two days to adjust to it like remember
when
andres kalaraga was hitting home runs in
colorado i've been fat for a long time
so imagine okay so quick story i go to
sheree's like hey i need to go to uh
home depot i said okay
fine i go to home depot i got to wear
the mask so i'm pushing the card i'm
putting stuff in
and then next thing i know i meet a few
fans and i'm just trying to be nice
and you know talk to him next thing you
know i just start
perspiring like crazy i'm sweating like
bullets and i'm thinking
the last time i felt like this was when
i first moved to colorado and i went up
to pike's peak
and i'm like why am i why is this
happening
and now like this person and this lady
is like i saw you in this film and like
oh my gosh my grandson can i take a
picture and i'm like
ma'am i'm about to pass out so i
literally just took it off
and i went out i literally left the car
ran outside
took a deep breath and i was like oh my
gosh i was
near having an anxiety attack and i and
i don't have that and i was like well
let's rewind what happened
doing this and it was one of those that
didn't have a lot of um
it wasn't like it was very thick and
it just me and i'm claustrophobic as
hell already so
it just really made me worse so now i've
had to figure out like which one will
allow me to be able to breathe so if i
am on the plane luckily when i was on
the plane
uh yesterday i didn't have that same
experience
you know and it is you know i've seen
certain flight attendants like
you know be cool with it and then not um
but
most important i think it's very
interesting when you're doing like this
and then you take the sip and you do
that and i'm thinking
how does that work i i just don't
understand and i'm not
you know i'll make fun of one situation
and that is the person that wears it by
themselves in the car
i just don't get it even even worse for
me is when tyron liu
was doing the interview behind his desk
and he had a mask and i'm like bro
you're by yourself what are you doing
from the camera like what you doing
you're on the zoom take the note
you can't get the virus over zoom i've
come to like the mask though because
most people that are still wearing masks
at this point are kami honkies anyway
and they're better when they're muzzled
so 100 the the commie honkeys are the
ones you know the the soccer moms with
the uh you know i'm with her stick
on the back of their prius they're the
ones messed
[Music]
i made one communist joke once said
gerard nomination
so last time i came to florida
i was sitting next to a kid and the kid
was eating his m m's
and the flight attendant told him you
know hey after you put one in your mouth
you have to cover yourself
right and i told her and i told the
flight and the kid was so we're in the
first class so we're sitting in the
front
the mom is sitting next to her daughter
on the on the next row and i'm sitting
next to him
and i think that he assumed he was with
me even though he was a little white boy
kind of weird like i'm not white you
know
and i said he's not doing that [ __ ] no
no no i'm just saying i'm not white like
obviously right and i said he's not he's
not going to do that [ __ ]
i said he's not going to do that i said
we're normal human beings here
okay he's going to eat whenever he's
done then he's going to put on his mask
so what you're doing is ridiculous don't
go overboard either and the guy just
looked at me like oh got addicted to the
people
what i'm getting at is that there's
going to be a sense of people defending
each other too
does that mean like you've got to step
up for other people the kid couldn't be
older than six years old
and then the i think he the guy just
looked at me he went to the he went you
just went to go do something else my mom
looked at me she says thank you
because it's annoying he's a little kid
that makes you
you're you're making him fear things
that are not real you know
what's different don't you think if
there was someone that was sitting next
to him
that felt offended yeah of course if
there's someone else
yeah then i could be like okay no
problem i don't know you pat
but we're sitting next to each other but
here's the other thing that i've noticed
is that
what about people that happen to get it
um don't they understand the whole and
this is gonna
oh man we're gonna go there the shedding
so meaning like you get anytime you get
a shot and stuff like that like you're
gonna shed right
the virus so yeah what if you're sitting
next to someone who you don't know
and you're shedding the virus and they
don't know it and they get sick
or they have accomplished interesting
yeah so these are things that like i do
believe like you know when people say
hey you should get this shot or whatever
before you travel
you wait 14 days you know there's you
can go get the shot
at the airport at some of the airports
so what does that mean like okay well
that's fine i get it but then i shed it
to some other person you're literally
maybe who may be
immunocompromised and now i put them at
danger
and i don't even know it i've never even
considered that and we don't think like
so it's very tough to figure out like a
real protocol on how to figure this out
and i feel really bad for anyone that
has you know
immune disorders my fiance has four
and you know it's it's v so i'm i
understand
yeah you know she's got the pcos you got
hashimoto's like she's got a lot of
different things going on so she can't
really be around certain people at
certain times but
you know she always tries to focus on
what beasley was saying it's like
you know how how can she protect herself
naturally
as much as possible and in all essence i
do believe that we
all should be figuring out regardless if
you take it or not
how can you boost your immunity
naturally yeah we should always
like i wish there i'm raising my hand
right now america like if i can help
seriously talk about health and fitness
this and that and the other
getting outside being you know being
healthy that way eating better
because i still go to the grocery store
and i'm sure we all agree frozen food
section aisle is still wiped out
i mean yeah like the bad stuff yeah we
got to do better
we got to do that i know because i take
them so if you go to my city they're
wiped out oh that was me
that's what i'm saying but i mean like
you know i and i'm not saying
everybody's got to eat like
some you know competitive bodybuilder
what i am saying is that let's let's try
to
rethink some of these options phil i
think you need a podcast that's what i
think yep i think you need a podcast i i
it would be interesting if you had do
you have a podcast currently right now
or not i think it'd be interesting if
you had your own podcast and you brought
athletes because you're connected you're
connected both through hollywood
you have friends in hollywood you have
friends in uh all sports i mean jamal
crawford's one of your buddies you guys
went to
yeah you guys play together you got guys
in the nba you guys got you got guys in
football
chad johnson wants to beat you in
bodybuilding you know
it would be interesting if you ran your
own podcast what that would look like so
you got strong opinions and at the same
time you're coming from a different lens
yeah a guy that's got a degree you would
look at a phil heath you're like oh he's
probably just a
you know meathead right yeah guys got a
degree in engineering yeah i confused it
with accounting yesterday but ronnie's
accounting you're engineering right
accounting seven-time mr olympia yeah
and at the same time he's got strong
opinions for himself and he's
independent i would watch it
yeah be it'd be interesting if you had
your own podcast but gang
if you're watching this we're at the end
thank you so much for joining the
podcast hit that subscribe button if you
enjoyed today's
podcast if you like to see us bring back
the same crew we had here today let us
know by smashing that
subscribe button expect short clips to
go out sometime later on this afternoon
with that being said i think the next
podcast we're doing
is not thursday this is a funny week i
got a lot of people coming to town this
week and i got a
one of the people that's coming to town
this week is a girl named brooklyn which
is my daughter
we've got a lot of people coming to town
this week so we don't know this is going
to be a little bit of a disruptive week
but i love the fact that she's
disrupting the week
are we doing it friday morning is the
next one friday morning give me the date
on what it is
whatever date it is say that again
thursday at 8 00 a.m it's gonna start
instead of nine thursday at eight a.m
this week podcast
daniel de martino booth is here thursday
8 a.m take care everybody bye-bye bye
you